Okay, so basically ma'am, apka jo abhi login url hai, right, jo usse log in karte hai,
uspe HRM ki apas complete permissions hai, apne check kar liye hogi.
Tke, to abhi tak aapne kya kya, masters wajhara create kiye the, assign kiye the, then uske
bhaad apne kuch contracts bhi laga liye hogi employees.
Anji.
Ji, tke.
Ab jo aapne ma'am contracts laga liye usme kuch funding jo the ho gayi the complete matlab
laga liye the apne.
Anji ma'am.
Tke ma'am.
To ma'am, ho cover karna hai part to bara se, ya ho clear aap uske aage kare.
Ma'am, sara starting se bata do merko, mere mind me re to raha ho raha ho raha ho raha
Okay, okay ma'am, okay.
Ma'am, agar aapko contract kisi bhi employee ko hme lagaana hota hai, to aap basi ye assign
salary template ka option rahega, basically.
Anji.
Tke, assign means, jais aji se aapko create karna hoga.
Tke, jo bhi employee ke liye, assign salary template mein, jabbi hum assign karte hai
Aapko contract ko, apne is teras ek option open hoga.
Ye, right.
Yaha se aapke paas employees aage hum ko aapko assign karna hai.
Basically, jitna bhi aappas total number of employees ho gye, wo saare aapki aapke aate
hain.
Anji.
Tke, apko aap search kar sakto ho, aayadat employee id aur name.
Right, jais bhi employee ko aapko lagaana hoga, apne search kiya.
For example, mujhe is employee ko lagaana hai, ma search karoogi name se, ho aage hain.
Then, yaha select box se aapko select karna hai.
Right, select karne ke baad aappas bottom ek button aayega, assign template ka.
Means, aap isko contract laga rahe ho aapki ke liye mein.
Tke, assign karoogi, assign karne ke liye aappas option hai, copy from salary template, import
from salary.
Dua option kya rahe the hai, ek to aapne contract template create kare rahe hai.
Right, jo aapne salary template create kiya ho, chaar tarah ke standard created hai.
With PF, without PF, without DSIPF.
Ab yaha fir aappas dosa option kya ho uskta hai, ki jo aapne previously employee ko lagaaya
waha hai.
Ye humne already employee ko lagaaya waha tha.
First date aari hai, toh aapne 1st December tak laga diya tha.
Tke, aage ke liye aap isko hi continue karna chaate ho December ke baad.
Tke, toh aap isko hi as it is copy karoogi, isme jo bhi aapko amount me changes, ya koi
head me changes, jo bhi karne hoge, wo aap kar sakte ho.
In case, for example, aapko further ke liye hi koi reduction head aage contract ke liye
assign karna hai, toh aap yaha se head bhi add kar sakte ho.
Tke, aap contract me change kar sakte ho, upcoming ke liye, 31 December ke baad ki contracts
me.
Tke, calculate karte hai hum, toh humare pas amount aajata hai, jo bhi contract ke according
amount create ho raha hoga, then aap next karoge, toh aap se date maangega, ki kap tak
ki liye aapko usse assign karna hai.
Tke, pehle wala jo contract hai, wo aapko already 31 December tak assigned hai.
Tke, toh aap jo aap aage assign kar sakte ho, December ke baad kar hi assign kar sakte ho.
Right, ek January se lagega, start date aap dekh rahe ho ki aap freeze aariye January
2026.
Agar mujhe November ka banana hai, ma'am.
Ha, aapko, man dekho kar November ka banana hai, toh phir jo previous contract hai wo aapko
remove karne padege, kyunki aapne I think December se banane ke liye bho raha tha na.
Ha na, toh wo phir previous contract.
Ja saar mein trial kari ho, toh toh mein November se karungi na.
Agar aap chahe ho, November se bhi create kar sakte ho, phir usme agar aapko head mein
koi changes hai na, wo create karne ke baad bhi ho jate hai.
Ye toh mein se contract create karne ka bata hote hai, agar aapko contract ki change karna
hai.
Tke, aap aap jesse batari ho na, aapko November ki for example salary banane hai, wo aap banane
sakte ho.
Uske liye aapko pati ye salary summary month wise ka use karke, aap pehle dates set kar
ke, kisi ek ki banane lete hai, jesse aapki hi kar lete hai.
Tke, ye salary summary month aapne dekha hoga, humne December ki create ki thi.
Tke, for example ye aapki November ki hoti, isse toh raha se aap November ki bhi banane
liye jega, wahi aapas jo ye hai, mark attendance month wise, November ki poore month ki kar
kete hai.
Asana aap mujhe hi bata ho, jesse maine na driver ki banane lete hai.
Haan.
Tke, toh wo maine shahe contract nahi lagaye tha usme.
Okay.
Aapke chekhna laga hai, nahi laga hai, kya nahi hai.
Usme aapke problem aarthi, nukse hua nahi.
Ye hai employee?
Ye hi.
Tke, aapne isse view kiya, aapko ye doubt hai, isko contract laga hai hai nahi.
Yaha pe na salary template rehta hai ye.
Okay.
Agar contract laga ho toh yaha wo show karega, yaha wo show nahi kara, means yaha pe contract
nahi laga hai.
Nahi laga ho.
Hum, wahi aapko contract lagana hai iska, yaha se sign salary template se, laga do
main?
Haan.
Tke, aapko click yaha pe click karna hai, select karoge assign template, then deko yaha
pe koi nahi aara hai, it means isko previous koi laga hi nahi hua.
Tke, toh aapko yaha se assign karna hai isse.
Tke.
Kya hai aapko iska, wahi 10,000 wala system?
Nahi with hai, with, with.
With lagana hai.
Haan.
PF, ESI both?
Aur Labour Welfare Fund bhi lagayega.
Toh aap basic itna rakhna hai, aapko amount batati jay.
Basic rakhna hai, humnei 14,390.
14,390.
Is tarah se aap basic amount enter karna, in case keun DA hai grade pe toh wo enter
jay sath pe, nahi hai toh aap isse skip kar dena, zero heat.
Okay.
Tke, aap deduction mein, waise toh wo ESI, PFI wo automatically calculate karega, jo
aapne khleet kiya tha.
Aapne hai, aapne hai, deko, automatic mein aara hai aapko ye 158.
Jee, 158 mein, up to amount hai.
Haan ji?
Jo, even up to amount hota hai.
Deko jo salary.
Up to amount hota hai.
Abhi humare paas ESI iska 101 hai.
Okay.
Hmm, toh itna hi rahega hai.
Deko ma'am kya hota hai, ye iska amount hai.
Chke, 14,390 ka 0.75%.
Haan ji.
Wo iska aayega, ESI basically.
Ye up to amount hai.
Up to amount hota hai, maksimum kaha tak jaa sath ta hai.
Abhi meri jo salary sheet mein iska amount hai 101.
Okay.
ESI.
Abhi me isko change kar sakte hai.
Ma'am up to amount kyu change karna hai?
I think 101 hi banega.
Ek min, main calculating kar lete hoon saath saath hai.
Akar hum dekhe humara hai, 14,390.
14,390 ka aap kya rahe ho 0.75%.
Haan, ye baithega aapka 107 kuch baithega.
Aapka kitna hai?
Ye mere paas 101 hai, ye iska amount iska.
Haan, toh itna hi baithega.
I think iski salary ke according.
Aapko fix karna hai 101, aap ye kya rahe hoon?
Ma'am ye 101 hi jaa raha hai iska ameesha se.
Mere peechi salary sheets dekhi hai.
Itna hi hai, jaise ye fix hi ho gaya ho.
Akar dekho fix rakhna hai, wo bhi kar se toh.
Wo ma'am 14,000 rupay pe laga rakhna hoon ne.
Jo aapka PFESI kaate hai na.
Jo peechi aap CSI karate hai.
Wo 14 ke upar basic pe laga raha hoon.
390 upar hai upar hai, 7 rupay aur upar hain.
Up to amount ka koi ye nahi hai, ki aap sochho ki 158 hi aayega wo.
Up to amount matlab ye nahi hota, wo percentage ke aisaab se calculate karega.
Jitna banega, kar 158 se zyada ban raha hoga na, toh wo 158 tak rakhega.
Iska matlab ye hota hai.
Abhi merko ye bata hoon ki, akar mujhe apni salary sheets se match karna hai, toh me isko 101 kar sakti hoon.
Debo, agar aapko karna hai, toh fir aap simple hai, hum isko ister aise nahi rakhege,
hum isko normal wala rakhege, add karoge.
Isko aapko rakhna hai, ESI employee contribution.
Isko aap rakhoge fixed.
Kittni value rakhni hai, who aap harte na.
Kittna badari ho jo na 101, agar aapko usi ke according banana hai.
Ma'am, ispe laga hoon ek bar 101.
101 karna hai ki kaise aayega.
Haan koi nahi, 101 karna hai.
Isko percentage hi jane the PF ko?
PF mein aayega, 1612, 1612.
12% iska dekh lukti mein ye baithe rakhe hai.
14, 399, 1726 baithe rakha hai.
Aapka kittne hai?
1612.
Haan toh fir ye bhi usse isaab se karlo, ye bhi basically aapko apne according rakhna hai.
Delete karoge.
Yaha pe PF hai aapka, isko bhi aap fixed kar sakte hoon.
Like fir ye fixed rahega, matlab itla hi rahega har salary contract mein.
Jabbi aap salary process karoge na, ukta hi amount rahega hai.
Agar next month ye change ho jaye toh?
Toh fir aap change kar sakte hoon.
Mai aapko wo bata dugi, aap salary mein bhi change kar sakte hoon.
Kittna rakho main amount batana?
1612.
Uske alawa employer contribution bhi hai kuch?
Ma'am, ye labor welfare fund hai.
Dishon reduction bhi aayega.
Ye toh hata do na employer contribution.
Haan ji.
Tika, yahaan se delete ho jayega.
Ab ek dosra aap kair rahe ho, labor welfare fund ye hai.
Ye kittna hai?
Ye ma'am 27 rupee.
27.
Ye aap contract mein laga rahe ho ma'am.
It means jabbi aap salary process karoge toh,
wo automatically ye deduction mein hi dekhayega.
Tika hai?
Mai aapko bhi bata de, agar aap ho contract change karna ho, salary process
ke baat karna ho, toh wo bhi aap kar sakte hoon.
Tika, ye kiya.
Then aap calculate karoge, wo salary dekhadega.
Ki gross salary itni banti hai.
Reduction aapki 1740 bani.
And paid salaries ki 12,650 bani.
Tika, aur Manu aap main ispe se advance cut karna hai.
Okay, fine.
Ab advance ka bhi aapka deduction raheta hai.
Waise toh.
Advance recovery.
Ye aapko kitna karna advance?
11000.
Toh ye aapko is month ka hi karna hoga.
Waise toh zero banega abhi ke liye.
Matab ek traj se contract mein toh zero hai.
Har month ki salary ke hi saab se hai.
Ye toh aapka.
Abhi ke liye hi zero karke,
we calculate karke assign karege.
Jab aapki salary process ho jaayega,
toh main waha pe bata doon ki aap kaise edit kar sakte ho.
Abhi aap mujhe ye bata ho,
agar hum yahi par isko
salary bana rahi hai.
Abhi contract laga rahi ho.
Salary nahi bana rahi ho yahan se.
Yahan se hum sirf contract laga rahi hai.
Contract ho gaya means,
ek salary structure hota hai.
Jaise ki aapko ye salary pattern hai aapka.
6 month ke liye, 7 month ke liye, 12 month ke liye.
Toh ho ek salary pattern assign raha hai.
Har month ki aapki
kam jaga,
wo hum banane ke baat patte hai.
Bas maine head select kar liye.
Incase hoga toh aap amount waha pe enter kar sakte ho.
Jo bhi rahega.
Then aap calculate kar hoge.
Next reyega.
Upka next karne ke baad aapko dates pe le jayega.
Aapki ma'am isme aapne sign nahi kari thi kiya?
Usko joining date?
Joining date.
Shahid mere Sutmeet sir ko bola goga.
Implore ki joining date nahi lagi ho hai.
But koi baat nahi hum na,
aap se laga ho contract bata doon.
Auguste laga doon.
Auguste pehle toh banaoge bhi nahi.
Auguste leke kap tak ke liye
Aapki contract hume future me assign karna hai.
Wo hoti hain aapki end date contract ki.
Toh kap tak ke liye
assign karna hai aapko ye?
26 tak toh karto ma'am.
March, April kaha tak karo?
Mai tak karto ma'am.
Mai tak.
Ye 31 maitha ho gaya.
Means 1 June se
new contract lagana padega.
Ya isi ko aap extend kar skte ho.
Aap assign karoge toh
contract employee ko assign ho jayega.
We can add it count 1 means
contract assigned jayega.
Abhi aapne ye contract lagaya hai.
Aap iski salary banao karte ho.
Toh ek cheez hai sbse pehle
salary banaane se pehle uske pay birthdays
aapko jisse maine bataya tha na.
Ye maitha laga diyate ma'am iski.
Laga diyate.
Akar pay birthdays lag gaye the,
then uske baad aap computer attendance
jahaan se aap salary banaoge.
HRM ke andar computer attendance.
Jis month ki
salary banaane hai. Aapko month select karna hai.
Toh kaunse month ki banaane hai.
November ki November.
Aap go karoge simple.
Toh aap saari employees ke list aajayega.
Aap search kar skte ho
single employee.
Jiski karne hai. Aapne uske pay birthdays
28 banaaye hai.
Toh 28 days ki
salary banaane hai basically aapko iski.
Aapne click
ki aapne select kiya.
Select karne ke baad aap process salary
karoge toh ye iske aajayega added.
Means iski salary
ban chuti hai. Aap jo salary baniye
hume wo dekhne hai. Toh
uske liye aap pass option hai salary
summary month wise.
Right. Yaha pe aap select karoge
2025. November month
ki salary dekhne hai. Aap yahaan se kuch bhi
select nahi karoge toh by default sabhi employees
ka data aega jo aapne banaya hua hua.
Right. November ki aapne
process karoge. Ye kuch aur
employees hai.
Toh aap jaisi ye employee hai.
Is employee ka deduction ye hai, amount ye.
Is accordingly iske salary ban rahi hai.
Aapki paas ye toh upar se aare.
Overall aariye jo system ne banake li.
Isne aapko jo bhi changes karne
ho di. Aap pass ye
view ka option hai.
Aap view karoge.
Hello.
Please.
Okay.
Okay. So
aap man dekh ho view hota hai. Ye toh aapki
salary create ho gayi. Tiki hai. Aap us
employee ki particular employee ki salary
me aapko jo bhi changes karne hai. Aap
view karenge. Usko corresponding structure
kura view karthe aap pass
ye uska open ho jayega structure.
Okay.
I starting se kabaad dete ho. HRM
ke andar yaha se apne salary
process ki. Right.
Process hone ke baad success aage
gaya means uski salary create ho gayi. Toh
isi ka next option hai salary summary
month wise. Naam se kya clear hota hai ki
aap ek particular month
ki salary dekh rahe ho employee ki.
Right. Toh aapko simple
month aapke month aur year select karke
go kar dena hai. Aap pass us month
mein jitne bhi employees ki salary bani
ho gayi ho aajayi.
Right. Ab isme se aapko
kisi aapne dekh liya
yaha pe kya rahe hain employee ki IDs
unka name corresponding department
designation. Jis month ki aap salary
dekh rahe ho November month.
Kitne payable days aapne banaye hai. Jis
hai kuch ke 30 hai, kuch ke 0, kuch ke 20 hai.
Right. Unki kya gross salary hai
kya deduction amount hai. Then
gross minus deduction karke jo employee
ki paid salary bachti hai ho.
Okay. Ab aapko
iske amount me kuch bhi changes
karne hai. Basically kisi bhi.
Toh aap pass uski corresponding view
rahe tha.
Okay. Aap view karoge.
View karne ke baad us employee
ka. Ye aap matlab pura complete
salary ka platform aapka structure uska
upan ho jayega.
Iska advance deduct karna
hoga.
Aap isme koi amount me bhi changes. For
example aapko basic increase karne hai,
kam karne hai aap wo bhi kar sakte ho.
Advance recovery. Ye deduction
rahega. Jo deduction ki
head aapko yaha se oye ge. Jo aapko
uske increase karne hai. Matlab pay scale increase
karne ke liye head ho gayi earning heads.
Aapko advance
dhalne hai?
11000 dhalne hai ma'am.
11000 aapne advance dhalne hai.
Aap jaisi 11000 dhalogue aap dekhogue
yaha pe ister aise pop up aayega.
Aur ye structure change karega.
Gross Salary deduction aur paid.
Ye isis aap se bad raha hai.
Aapke coning ye okay hai. Matlab itni
gross salary ban rahe thi.
12,740 deduction aur paid uska
691 bad raha hai.
691 ye hai?
Basic bhi okay hai.
So, ab uske bad aap pass
yaha pe ab diku ye to save
hua yaha pe save hua hai.
But ye tab tak reflect nahi karega bottom
me jab tak aap uske remarks dhalke save
nahi karoge. Means aap
koi bhi change karo. Jab tak aap
remarks dhalke save nahi karoge. To
actual save nahi hoga.
Aapne remarks enter karne
ki jo aapne change kiya hai.
For example, maine advance recovery ka change kiya hai.
To maine ister aise remark
usne enter gaya. Save karoge
to aap pass pop up aajayega ki ye save
ho gaye hai.
Ye save ho gaye hai. Ab then aap isko
view karoge to iske
ye be change ho gaye aapko.
Okay ma'am.
Okay ma'am. Matlab aap
basically view karke koi bhi change kar
sakte hai. Ab agar aapko
kisi aur employee me bhi in case aapko
lagta hai ki kisi aur employee me bhi aapko deduction
aur ho sab head karna hai. For example, ye employee
hai koi bhi hum le lete hai.
Iski salary jo process hui hai
isme aapko deduction head bhi daalna hai.
To aap yaha se add karoge
kaunsa deduction head hai.
Aap direct select karke, amount karke bhi
save kar sakte ho remark darke.
Okay ma'am.
Okay.
In case aapko koi aisa head chahiye
jo yaha pe nahi aara. Aisa ho sakte aapko
earning head me bhi koi aisa head chahiye.
Koi bhi head ka name
jo bhi aapko lagte hai. Koi head aapko
chahiye aisa. Head aap create
kaunse kar sakte ho. Yaha pe settings
me HRM setup milega aapko.
Right. Yaha pe
payroll master hai. Basically salary ka
jitna bhi hota hai, wo humara payroll master
ke andar aata hai. Okay.
Aap ispe click karoge. Ye
earning heads hai. In case aapko koi earning
head additional chahiye. Aap basic
hai, wo hai. Aapko lagte koi conveyance, allowance
dena hai, kuch bhi. Koi bhi name ka head chahiye.
Ispe click karoge.
Kuch to head aapko upar mil jayege. Like
HRA, medical law and special events hai na. To aap
direct yaha se tick karke bhi save kar sakte ho.
In case agar upar hai aapko
head. Okay.
In case agar inme se koi nahi hai,
to aap add new karoge. Apne hi saabse
name enter karoge. Jo bhi hai head ka.
Save kar doge to wo head create
ho jayega aapka.
Karke save
zarur karna hota hai.
Same earning head ki liye hai, same
deduction head ki liye.
In case aapko deduction head add karna ho.
Okay.
Salary template me koi change nahi
jayega. In case agar bo template kisi bhi
employee ko assign hota hai.
Okay. Agar aapko change karna
hoga na fir ye salary je se hum process karte
aap waha se change kar sakte ho. Jo aapne
salary bhi dekhne. Salary summary month
size me aap yaha se kar sakte ho.
Nei to contract bhi dwaara assign kar sakte ho
future ke liye.
Aur baaki aapko contract
view karna ho kisi employee ka. To aap
employee ke andar option hai. Jaise
abhi isi ka hi dekh lete hai jo ek employee
aapne jis ko assign kiya.
Yaha se aap employee view karo ge
to salary template aara tha na
wahi se hi aap dekh sakte ho.
Isi tarah se main
employee hota na
humare paas, aap pass employee ke list hain jo.
Yaha se aap
search karoge
jiso employee ko karna hai.
Aapne employee search kiya.
Asabhi employee ko humne assign kiya.
Aap ispe click karoge yaha pe aap
pass bottom me rehta hai salary template.
Ispe click karke
Jo bhi template assign hai usko dekh
sakte ho.
Yaha se bhi new add hota hai, but wahi se
preferable rehta hai kiki waha se aapko
calculation amount dik jaata hai.
Aapko accounts number darliye hain.
Okay, bank details basically.
O salary details
ka section.
Jaise kuch loko ke
cheque bante hain, to kaisi
kuch show hoga ki inke cheque bane ge
kuch aisa ho sakte hain.
Malha aap isto aise kya rahe ho ki
salary via cheque de rahe hain jo.
Abhi jinke bank account number
to honge wo to main add kar doon.
Aap yaha payment
mention kar sakte ho via
cheque karke.
Aapne kuch pop up
aayega ki ye
via cheque bane ge.
Okay, matlab aap uspe pop up
chah rahe ho.
Remarks me daal sakte ho ma'am, agar aap chah
ho to fir wo.
Jo remark ki details rahe the hain aap usme
enter kar sakte ho.
Itna hi part hai ma'am
hai salary process ka sara.
Waise abhi theek hai aap
payment mode me likho RTGS
jiski jaari hain. Yaha pe likho cheque.
Aapko pada rahega.
Ye cheque se jayegi, ye RTGS se jayegi.
Aap yaha likh doon ki
toh ma'am yaha pe fayda ye ki
ek hi bari abne ghar.
Matlab save kar diya, har man tha phu karni ki
zarat nahi hain.
Matlab mereko ye tha ki agar me salary slip nikal lo isme do
ma'am.
Jo aap yaha enter karoge
ye paanch details hai, bank name
branch. Ye aapki salary slip pe
reflect ho diye.
Koi doubt, koi query
ma'am.
Abhi toh query tab aayegi.
Aap ek par kar lijega.
Koi baat nahi, maine recording kar liye.
Aapko reference ki liye share kar doon.
Thank you ma'am.